[Music]
rich paul has risen from selling vintage
jerseys out of the trunk of his car
to running one of the fastest growing
sports agencies in the world
representing some of the world's most
famous athletes with an unapologetic
swagger
and purpose he's inspired devotion from
his clients
and disdain and dismissal from
entrenched interests competitors and
institutions alike
i always said the dents in the man's
armor show that he's battle tested
while agents are usually the guy behind
the guy or woman
we live in a different world when it
comes to star players and their reps
and rich paul is a big reason why he's
put the business out front
powerfully making the case that
different voices need to be at the
negotiating table
not just on the court i spoke with rich
to find out what the rest of us can
learn from a career spent relentlessly
being true to yourself
and where you came from i'm not going to
be a yes man to you
because you're paying me a fee
[Music]
so rich first of all it's really nice to
see you i wish we were
together and let's talk about where you
came from
what are the reflections you have as you
think about
your own origin story and and how it
plays now and and how you think about it
in in 2021 well
i started out the trump and so to make
it from the trunk to beverly hills
is a blessing but i'm not satisfied i'm
not complacent
i know there's a lot of work ahead to be
done to continue to inspire and be
impactful for those that's coming behind
me
despite their skin tone or their gender
you know my city was very segregated
growing up
but my parents didn't teach that they
didn't allow that
and i never wanted to be that way
and i have all type of friends
i treat everyone the same because that's
how i was raised
so tell me what you're looking at so i'm
looking at a picture of my dad
young and
my mom and myself my mom was
had a drug addiction and i know every
time she tried to break it it was one
day at a time
my mom did end up getting clean
she was a very strong woman she was the
life of the party she was
extremely helpful to give you the shirt
off her back type of person
my dad was always there he was always
johnny on the spot he was always
very hard on me and my brother and
sisters
because he knew what the world brought
forth
and he was always trying to prepare us
for a time when he wasn't going to be
around
and that we had to navigate throughout
on our own and i couldn't be more
appreciative of the makeup
and the dna of these two people
uh two of the most important people to
ever be in my life
and i know i'm making them proud so
that's that's very important
rich learned from a young age how to
sell and early on he identified vintage
sports jerseys as a niche
while his personal style he says aspired
more toward ralph lauren
he also liked a good jersey and saw lots
of peers did too
one day in 2002 a 21 year old rich threw
on a warren moon jersey
it matched his sneakers and headed to
the akron airport for a flight to
atlanta
waiting for the same flight an already
well-known high school basketball phenom
named lebron james
the once in future king complimented the
jersey and asked him where he got it
can you see this war moon can you see
this that's the one huh
yeah this the one don't ask me why i
wore that jersey
but you know seeing these young men at
the gate
and striking up a conversation based
upon that that specific jersey
for that to lead to what's now a 20-year
friendship
and a business relationship and a
brotherhood
it's just fake you know
rich quickly became a trusted friend and
advisor part of a small
and influential inner circle he joined
lebron
randy mims and maverick carter two
longtime friends of lebron also from
akron
to create lrmr marketing rich curated
lebron's appearances and image and
explored acting music and producing
before settling on becoming an agent he
ultimately joined caa to work under
lebron's agent
leon rose
in 2012 rich left caa to start his own
agency clutch sports
last year it ranked seventh in the value
of contracts negotiated
at 1.7 billion clutch sports decides who
wins the championship clutch sports
decides
who the best team in the world is so one
of the things that
becomes clear about your success
is the relationship that that you have
with your clients
and i want to show you something that
one of your earliest clients
uh tristan thompson said about you and
get you to react to it on the other side
i remember um the first time i called
rich i'm like
uh good afternoon mr paul and he's like
hey what's up chris i'm like
okay like it threw me off because you
know like the first time you meet
someone like my mom always taught me is
a kiss wish i'm 16 17. she's like
have manners be polite so i was like
hello mr paul this is uh tristan
thompson here
and then he's like hey what's up what's
up double t what's going on like
okay i'm like man i'm like alright well
this guy's like like you know it makes
me feel comfortable i'm like yeah what's
up what's going on
another reason why i got with rich
especially just because i wanted to
have some represent me that understands
me understands my lifestyle understand
what i went through as a kid you know
like me being a black man and being
represented by rich paul who's also an
african-american man
it's huge because well me and rich
always talk about it we want to find a
way to put more
people like us in position of power and
i think what rich is doing
is a is a big step and then i think you
know he's not finished you know everyone
thinks like you know yeah he's you know
one of the top agents and that's great
finally i know one thing about rich paul
he's never going to stop you know he
always keeps the
the the the the wheels are always
turning his brain is always working
the man hardly sleeps i got to find a
way to get him some rest i'm like go on
vacation brother like
this is too much
oh that was great um yeah you know
tristan is someone who knows me better
than anybody
uh i've i've been with him since he was
16 years of age
going back to that time that he
described
he came to cleveland and we kind of
talked and
you know he was really young and and
impressionable about things
and so moving forward when he got on
campus
at texas he called me one day and was
like
bro i need a car i got to find a way to
get me a car and i said why would you
need a car on campus
say you're on a basketball team what do
you need a car for yeah and he's like
because
this person got a car that person got in
the car said tristan
it don't matter what they have you got
to put blinders on
you're trying to get to the finish line
and so i said
at the end of the day you have a goal
achieve that goal build good habits
and i can guarantee you you're going to
be able to get whatever you want
[Applause]
so that was one obstacle we overcame and
so
seeing tristan uh he knows me and i know
him
we love each other and when you have
that it makes
me able to do my job better because i
can tell him something without worrying
about him firing me
or i don't have to create a yes
environment
i want to make sure we talk about that
because i think that's a really
important
thing and and tristan mentioned it to me
and and i've heard you talk about it
before which is this whole notion of
you embrace having these tough
conversations with these guys
they have been deified in many ways and
yet
part of what you do is speak truth to
them
how are you able to do that do you think
the foundation has to be respect
and you have to be respect each other
and if you respect each other
you can have the hard conversations and
so we've had the hard conversations i've
had
the conversations where my guys don't
pick up the phone for two days
and then they call me and say you know
what bro you was right man
and they go both ways and i say to them
if i'm ever out of line
hold me accountable as well yeah because
this is not
about you playing a sport this is about
you surviving the game of
life i wanted to be liked by everybody
part of rich's confidence comes from
that tight circle he's a part of
a group that's become famous enough to
inspire their own documentary
called more than an athlete
it was through making that that they met
the legendary jimmy iovine
the multi-hyphenate impresario who
produced some of the biggest records of
all time
created interscope records invented
beats by dre
with dr dre and went on to run apple
music
i met the crew i met lebron rich
maverick and randy and
i found it to be really uh just very
very impressive
you know they had the right attitude the
right approach they were
they were together for a long time it
was a real team
what i was shocked about was the lack of
infighting
the clear roles and so
i'm not surprised that with that kind of
structure infrastructure and foundation
that they get things done
um you know that's
meeting jimmy at a time in which we were
all still growing
as young men and as much as he was
impressed with us he was impressed with
him yeah
and this is jimmy iveen and we're
sitting in his office
and as he discussed
about our roles and the respect respect
that we have for each other
oftentimes we come from a place where
there can only be one person that's the
man
and that mentality sticks with you as
you climb the ladder
but maverick and i live together randy
lived by himself
on the floor below us and lebron lived
in an apartment next to maverick high
and i think one of the things that
brought us closer together
was the fact that we knew that if push
came to shove
we had each other and so you know
jimmy's a mentor of mine
and some of the things he's done you
know he was always a supporter of our
culture
so i want to show you one more thing
that he said because it builds on
exactly uh what you're talking about if
we if we can look at
one more clip if you got jimmy twice
that's pretty good
there's an enormous opportunity in
african-american culture
that is under-resourced underutilized
and under-appreciated in this country
african-american culture is brilliant
it's powerful
the whole world copies it it's
inspirational it's influential
what you see now is corporations come
around so
we need diversity you don't need
diversity
you want diversity because this is an
extraordinary
resource and what you're seeing now
in lebron's camp with rich et cetera
are these things coming to fruition and
um
i think it's just the beginning that
that's a big statement
and and i feel like you are at the nexus
of something
important that that jimmy identified
there yeah i agree
diversity is something you want
diversity is something that i want as
the ceo
of of clutch sports group when you talk
about black culture
i think a lot of times people get so
caught up on the color
versus the talent you know and versus
the
the genius that these men and women
have within and when you
evaluate the challenges they had to
overcome
and to still be successful
he's right like i want that person
don't give me the person who had a road
map
and who was able to have 10 different
people pick up the phone call
and make sure they was higher or make
sure they was accepted to this
university
give me the person who had to fight for
everything
who was evaluated and critiqued
differently
from their peers and they still
persevere and still
give me that personal peace
even as institutions and individuals
undertake a long overdue reckoning
around race
inequality and systemic injustice
there's still a ways to go
in 2019 the ncaa made a new rule
requiring
agents representing student athletes to
have a bachelor's degree themselves
which many saw as directed right at rich
to the point where lebron and others
derisively called it
the quote rich paul rule how racist it
was to require
you know that this guy has a four-year
degree a college education
rich wrote a stinging rebuke in the
athletic explaining how this move would
discourage people from poor backgrounds
often people of color
from entering the industry six hours
after the article was published the ncaa
backed down
it was a striking example of what's
coming at him almost every day
i have no doubt that there were agents
behind the scene
that were pushing for that in hopes that
it would compromise
somebody like a rich paul there are a
lot of people who
have come at you hard i mean and have
tried to discourage you and
obviously in some ways it's out of their
own self-interest but
i i can't imagine that that feels good
or is easy
i always said the dents in the man's
armor show that he's battle tested
and if you were able to see my armor
you know mako couldn't fix it it's got
some dents i think that's fair to say
yeah and it was a fight
you know no one wants to give you credit
for what you achieve with lebron
right but at the same time it's like
oh well if you go with them it's going
to be all about lebron
and it's a small ecosystem so you got
assisted coaches that's
saying things to parents disco it's all
discouragement and
i think that's the mentality of if rich
paul is on top today
in order for me to be on rich paul's
level i got to push rich paul
down or i got to convince this media
person to say something bad about
rich paul but you know i think over time
people start to stop
listening to the discouragement and to
the false narratives
and to the critique of others
and really start to take things for what
it really is
and take me for who i am so as we wrap
up
sort of on on that point i did want to
ask you you know
when it comes to sports it does feel
like we have seen something meaningful
shift over the past few years certainly
over the last year
and one of those shifts has been who's
pulling the levers of power in many ways
you know we
seem to be moving away from a point
especially in the nba where white
general managers sort of have the
the final say we have players who are
empowered in many different ways we are
starting to see
ownership changes and and owners think
about
their teams differently their their
players differently
do you agree with that is that is that
something that that you have seen
because you are in those
corridors of power in many ways
i think it varies um i do think there's
an open-mindedness
more today than it was of yesterday
yesterday's owners versus today's owners
yes they're definitely different from an
executive perspective we still have a
long way to go
but they're trying you know they're
trying
and that's all you can ask for all you
can ask for is effort
you know acknowledgement effort
understanding
and a willingness it's a different time
it really is
and i do think that going forward
there is going to be the world will be
different and there will be
an ability to be okay with
the skin tone of somebody being
different than yours
and the sun would definitely shine
brighter
if we can ever get to that point
i couldn't be more appreciative about
what we've been able to build over the
years
i'm blessed to represent the guys that i
do no matter what pick they were
they're all great young men we support
each other and i know this word is very
cliche but we are a family
we want to see each other win and we
just really want to see each other do
[Music]
better
you